foreign
hello folks
I hope people are well
very pretty in the thumbnail Robin
That's
thank you I will I will I will take the
compliment and
move forward
ah
who do I think the was the best actor in
terms of ability that played the doctor
I don't know I don't really
think of actors in terms of abilities
sometimes I'll think like in terms of
range which is sometimes what people
mean
um in that they can be cast in a wider
array of roles uh than others
I probably give it to Capaldi
maybe with tenant secondary
but
you know that's quantifying I like I can
quantify it a performance I can tell you
what's a good performance but being like
good actor bad actor better actor I tend
to I tend to narrow it down to more you
know better suited wider range there are
some actors who I have described in the
past as
um limited instruments in that there's
only a handful of things that they
appear to be particularly good at and
um that's not necessarily a mark of bad
acting that is a
um unless you measure acting skill by
range alone which I don't think should
ever be the only measure
I should be asleep at ADHD uh see that's
that is funny uh Serenity Productions uh
insomnia is one of the few things I
don't deal with so like
I don't have very very many neurotypical
friends
try to act shocked but
um the simple truth is that
um I think I'm the only neurodivergent
person I know who doesn't have problems
sleeping
so I I will I will take that
uh as a as a win and do my best uh
to embrace it
because I have had problems sleeping
before but it was mostly in college I
think it was a combination of really bad
life habits and not being consistent
about when in the day I took my meds and
I because
since then it hasn't really come up
since and I don't think it's inherent to
my particular
um
ADHD
manifestation
I should not need an extra two hours
from my exam but ADHD
whoo
I didn't mean it to be but if this is
going to become the uh the ADHD sharing
live stream I'm here for it I get it
um carowind will not uh be joining us
um this evening so uh it is going to be
Pirates and Gozer on
um
uh moderation uh on your own shouldn't
be too tough though we usually do all
right limited instruments sounds like a
Terry Pratchett book title ah
huh
I'm autistic and can't stop sleeping as
soon as I get out of bed I want to nap I
use it though
that was me in my
teens and 20s like I could sleep to noon
very easily
um that's not something I can really do
anymore and I think that's just I've
I've
um
I've kicked the Habit is the best way I
can think to put it
how do we stop the conservatives ah
that is a uh a
very broad question
um
uh the the short answer is uh not
playing the game by their rules because
they are rigging the game now that is
not me saying you you go out and you
start causing chaos and destruction
exactly what form that takes is going to
vary by situation by person by country
but the major thing of the conservatives
overall and like
I'm I can be hesitant to to lump you
know knowing how many UK folks are in my
audience I can be hesitant to lump all
conservatives in all areas under one
umbrella because while conservatism
certainly has a lot of consistencies and
how it manifests uh across the world
the nature of
um well much like fascism in fact the
nature of
um British conservatism is not the same
as American conservative heck New
England conservatism is not the same as
Southern American conservatism so I I
can be
um
a bit hesitant to make broad statements
about the conservatives but what I will
say is a very consistent tactic of all
of them has been to
uh insist that we follow the rules and
to do everything they could to ensure
that those rules are stacked in their
favor I mean we've seen that in a very
literal sense of seeing
um trans people hauled out of public
hearings you know where they're giving
testimony on potential legislation if
they go even a few seconds over their
time being escorted out by security
that's technically following the rules
we saw with tennis in Tennessee where
they I was going to say attempted they
did successfully expel two black members
of the legislation on the basis of them
quote unquote breaking rules of decorum
something that no one had ever been
expelled from the legislative body body
for doing and they hide it under the
guise of we're just enforcing the rules
again exactly what shape don't play the
game by their rules
um takes is going to vary so I'm not
making a broad statement of what you do
but as a base level
don't let them set the terms don't play
by their rules because their game is
rigged
so that's that's the short version of
what we deal with the uh the
conservatives
uh what nail colors am I doing I'm just
doing a light purple on this one because
I I had that one yellow
um but the yellow is so thin I had to do
that
um a bit thick and unfortunately it kind
of bunched up and peeled off so I'm just
trying to
get this going
ah
to celebrate my birthday and my exams
being over well congratulations I
decided to release my worst best video
ever tomorrow I also blame my ADHD uh
like
the thing is
as you come to better understand your
ADHD
it's uh it's a very easy thing to joke
you know about how like oh God
everything just comes back to my ADHD
the thing is when you actually stop and
think about it
the degree to which ADHD thinking or
lack of control on your thought process
influences basically everything you do
when you actually start mapping that out
yeah it's gonna catch you off guard
so like
oh how do I want to put this and well I
know how I want to put this how am I
going to put this
there is a video that I want to do for
the Vera wild Channel this this year
which I've been thinking about for a
very long time
that would be talking about
Kink and my relationship to it
and the thing is the way that I relate
to that entire aspect of my own intimate
life is
heavily informed by ADHD
uh I realized that a couple years ago
and I was like oh
well crap
I remember when I was a kid I was told
the difference between Democrats and
Republicans was that
um Republicans didn't want to raise
taxes
that was never the only difference that
was never even the main difference
you look at nearly
every
positive social thing anything that has
ever made the world better outside the
scope of did it make the rich richer it
is something that the conservatives have
opposed
they opposed
um a 40-hour work week they opposed
weekends they opposed
um laws against child labor they are
actually moving to loosen laws against
child labor currently they oppose Social
Security they opposed uh on the
unemployment program they opposed food
stamps they opposed Medicaid they oppose
Medicare they uh oppose the Civil Rights
Movement they opposed women's suffrage
they opposed gay marriage like literally
all of it and conservatives not
necessarily Republicans the specific
attitudes of the
individually named parties Canon have
shifted but
this is what conservatives do that's
what they have always done
and where they can't prevent it they
will try and roll it back
you know it's not exactly a new
observation but
when you say make America great again
the first question should always be when
was it great
when are you trying to roll us back to
uh
flannel is the uniform of the vermonter
and the queer Femme yeah why do you
think we have so we have so many uh
Sapphic queers up here
um
but yes there there is literally a
Vermont flannel company who makes pretty
good stuff
say
uh Supreme Omega reminder
um well I do try and keep up with the
chat uh super chats are the one way to
guarantee that I will get to your
question
um and you get a heart from me and a
slightly awkward one because I don't
want to mess up the nail I just painted
hope you are well
comic writer question thoughts on Mark
Miller
his pros and cons as a writer in your
view because he's a very divisive
Creator amongst comic fans I am not a
fan
uh of his work I
I dislike him for very similar reasons
that I dislike Garth Ennis he has very
edgelord instincts
um and honestly I have not even read
enough of his stuff to know if I would
think of him as well as garthennis
because garthennis is not devoid of
strong storytelling instincts but it's
also buried under edgelord nonsense a
lot of the time which is why I don't
click with him and as I'm rather fond of
saying with garthennis he's about 70 as
clever as he thinks he is Mark Millar
I've I've not actually read that much of
his actual stuff I know what he has
written I know some of the criticisms of
the stuff he has written I'm actually
trying to think if I've actually read
his actual work or how much of it I'm
just familiar with
wait a minute give me a second let me
pull up uh
a bibliography
let's see nope didn't read that didn't
read that didn't read that oh didn't
realize he wrote for 2018 and did Judge
Dred for a while I mean that's a that's
a fit that makes sense I suppose
um
nope nope nope nope he wrote for Sonic
the Hedgehog oh early 90s so start of
his career all right
uh
DC nope nope nope nope nope nope nope
nope nope now Marvel nope
oh God he wrote trouble oh crap I didn't
read that but I am familiar
a Civil War I have not read I will
eventually
um
I'm coming
[Music]
yeah I haven't read any of those wait
didn't he do hang on I'm trying to check
something here
oh [__] he did Old Man Logan
I've read Old Man Logan that was trash
that was absolute garbage like the Logan
movie that took the Barris bones
iconography of that comic is a very good
movie but that comic is garbage
oh it's so bad
oh god oh I don't know what his Pros
would be I think
so if I was trying if I was trying to be
nice I can look at how many good
adaptations there have been of his work
and admit that there is
often enough at the heart of what he
writes a core starting premise with a
lot of potential
it seems to take other people to bring
whatever's good there out of it because
oh my God
hmm
there's a new vid from the leftist cooks
that talks about sex is very good they
cover Kink I actually don't watch them
and like and there isn't a reason for
that I just haven't I haven't engaged
with their uh
with their stuff
you watch The Little Mermaid before
going to see the new version apparently
Ariel getting her voice back was so
magical she also gained shoes see I
really would have advised against
re-watching the original before doing
that because you're it's just gonna beg
the comparisons and I don't I I don't
think that's gonna if you're if you're
actually trying to give the new one a
fair Shake I don't think that's a great
idea doing that
could you go a little more in depth on
not playing by their rules uh uh what
some ways we play by their rules in our
lives if someone is kicked out of court
what should they have done
so
okay when I say so let's take it out of
um the legal and the legislative context
for a second the basic thing for someone
like me someone who's on YouTube and who
and like something that's very big and
with content creators like me is the
debate structure you know come debate me
don't
when I say don't play by the rules if
you are a leftist don't
you will not ever convince them to
publicly relinquish any part of their
position you are making yourself
vulnerable to Their audience and you are
just giving them stuff they're gonna
pull clips from Forever they are setting
the rules of that engagement so don't
engage
now that doesn't mean never address or
talk about these people
um
uh innuendo Studios uh has a whole
series on the alt-right Playbook which
talks about a lot of sort of some of the
ideas I'm talking about here but like
when they say this is what you have to
do
don't believe them
because when they're trying to sound
reasonable they don't intend to be
because the thing is especially right
now one can argue whether the whether
the thing I'm about to say specifically
has always been the case with
conservatives but especially right now
there is no interest in finding Middle
Ground
at all they want to steamroll and they
want to control the whole thing so
anything that is said under the premise
of well look you should work with us you
should meet us halfway is a trap
it is a trap and I know how paranoid
that sounds
I know that it sounds like I'm going you
know we do not negotiate with
conservatives but the thing is the
current
agenda that has been laid out again I'll
narrow it down to America by the
Republican Party
is not one that you can meet halfway
with
when their Rank and file and their party
members and their agenda and their
presidential candidates are laying out
flatly
we will strip the rights away from trans
people we will remove the possibility of
learning
anything we don't like which is a lot of
stuff from any Library school or public
what's the halfway negotiation with that
you let them strip away the rights from
half the trans people
you let them remove half the books no no
you don't
there was a time I'd say about 20 some
odd years ago where
there was more room to meet in the
middle
if only because of the Optics because
thanks to Trump the party has been
hijacked by its most extreme elements
and they are steering the ship either
directly or by or by uh threat of not
cooperating with uh the older School
conservatives and that's not me trying
to let the older School conservatives
off the hook because they have signed on
with these people they have missed every
opportunity to actively expel them from
their movement and force them to become
a completely unviable third party as the
Democrats have repeatedly done with the
far left so the Republicans had their
chance to do that and they have whiffed
it
repeatedly
so when I say there there was a time
when there was negotiation possibility I
don't want you to think for a minute
that I'm being like and they were decent
people and you know if they're still
around maybe we can work with them no
like I still have just as many problems
with them
but the fact that they used to care
about the decorum they used to care
about the Optics gave leverage whether
or not they actually cared didn't matter
because they were prepared to behave as
if they cared how this all looked they
don't anymore
they don't care how this looks therefore
neither should we because if we're still
approaching these problems with the idea
of cooperation decorum and meeting in
the middle when they are not going to do
any of those things no matter what they
say you go by what they do not what they
say
you go by their behavior and what they
are doing
they will not do any of that for us why
are we going to do it for them why is
the Democratic party repeatedly more
interested in trying to placate
soft
um
soft conservatives rather than actually
appeal and build up a strong Coalition
within its own base
why is the progressive weighing of the
democratic party pushed aside so that we
can appeal to the middle
there isn't much middle left
the country is incredibly divided and
that is awful that's not a good thing to
be clear
but what middle are you appealing to
and especially when you are failing to
defend and
um
just support
the people who are voting for you not
because we like you and I say we I'm a
progressive I don't like the Democrats
but I will vote for you if only for
damage mitigation because you are not
currently trying to actively wipe me out
that doesn't mean I like you and I
deeply resent the fact that you just
assume that you can count on my boat and
I resent it even more that as of right
now yeah unfortunately you kind of can
and I hate that that means you think you
can discard me
but they need to realize this is part of
what the Democracy theorize is part of
what got them into trouble in the first
place
because there were a hell of a lot of
disaffected people
around the time that Trump started
running
there were a lot of disaffected young
people especially young men
and the Democrats
were too busy trying to meet the
existing Republican base halfway
they didn't care about the young people
who weren't politically engaged
and the right got to them first
the right got to them through gamergate
and it got to them through these this
pipeline of mentality through the uh
originally being called anti-sjw and now
anti-woke sentiments
the Democrats have been as a as a party
not necessarily everyone who votes that
way but as a party I've been trying to
meet the existing Republican Rank and
file in the middle
and it's not helping
and obviously I've gone off on a whole
thing but like
when they say
you know we'd work with you if only
you'd give us X
don't
don't give them that
because they're not going to work with
us
and I don't like I don't like taking an
All or Nothing mentality it's actually
very much against my own instincts just
as a person
I don't like it
but there isn't a middle ground
with people who are currently seeking
the destruction of knowledge
and the wiping out of entire groups of
people
that's not a position that you meet in
the middle with
and if you're willing to
you have no business holding power
ah
so that's
oh
that that was uh that was a thing
255 A.D thank you very much for the
Super Chat reasonable conservatives
don't exist anymore I think reasonable
conservatives were in reality always a
severe minority but they used to be the
front facing part of the Republican
party they were they never typified the
party they were never the exemplars of
what uh conservatives were but they used
to be put forward as like the friendly
face of conservatism they're not even
bothering with that anymore
so that should tell you a lot when when
masks come down
when people don't need to use euphemisms
anymore when people don't need to use
dog whistles anymore
um that's a real bad sign for what they
believe they can get away with
because they don't have to hide it
ah
Bumble Homestead ooh thank you for the
Super Chat and I love the name
I was willing to give them room to grow
when I was young but they've gotten
worse and now my kid is contemplating
leaving the country when they graduate
No Quarter I mean the thing is I was two
but and I'm not necessarily going to say
that that's a bad youthful Instinct be
careful who you extend it to
because I would say that
it's not uh an unhelpful thing
for younger people to give those their
own age
some hope under the idea of room to grow
but you also need to realize when
somebody has already become what they're
going to be
and the odds of them ever backpedaling
or ever-changing tract are so thin like
the
ah I hate that I'm about to say this and
bring this up but take JK Rowling I am
beyond exhausted with anyone who dares
say to me
even hypothetically what if she changed
her mind
she's not going to
she's not she has made clear who she is
she has dug her heels in she has been
this thing publicly long enough and she
is old enough that there is no reason to
believe that she's gonna go oh but I
sell so much to learn she thinks she
knows
she's done she did her growing and it is
and it was growing into the person that
she now is publicly and that's the thing
while
there is a wonderful sentiment to you
know don't give up on people people can
always change yes
within a spectrum
there is ultimately a fundamental nature
to people
now there's just the core of Who You Are
and you can be a good version of who you
are or a bad version of who you are but
that core
is first of all not going to move very
much and second of all gets more and
more and more and more solidified as you
age
so
I do believe that people can change I
have to believe that because if I
thought I was right now still the same
person who I was 20 years ago I would be
the most depressed morose person you
would meet
because the idea that I couldn't change
from a lot of that nonsense would
be an existential nightmare for me but
that having been said
there is a lot fundamentally about me
that will never change I will never stop
having ADHD
I will never stop being trans I didn't
recognize that that was what I was for a
long time but
you know understanding the basic
fundamentals of me
the nature of my ability to empathize
the nature of how my brain works the
nature of my sense of self
these things I can come to a better
understanding of but they are unlikely
to fundamentally shift now with those
same core components I can still be a
better or worse version of myself
foreign
but again the thing to remember is that
tends to solidify as you get older
and while it's a great idea to think you
know people can always change they can
but the longer they remain the same
thing the less you need to hold on to
that because at a certain point it stops
being hope and stop and starts becoming
delusion
because if you are still holding on Hope
for someone who has publicly and flatly
and repeatedly said and done awful
things and has had to explain to them
why it's awful and is still doing it
you are wasting your time and your
effort and your energy trying to
continue to reach someone who doesn't
want to be reached
find somebody else
unheard Sirens Incorporated ooh that's a
good name too we got some good names in
the chat tonight 100 agree with
everything you said thank you I
appreciate that do I have a music album
I love love love
like Tony Mitchell or corn or both
uh those are some interesting ones to
float out there I don't really listen to
albums very much anymore
um I listen to them more as a kid
because you know that was there when I
was I was young uh there were basically
two ways to consume music there was the
radio which you know was usually themed
um so you were listening to a certain
type of music from the radio it was a
rock station or a country station or was
a top 40 station
um a top 40 was the most variable
because taste changed with time uh and
you had and that's obviously not an
album format or you bought and listened
to full albums
but I don't really listen to music that
way anymore not in the streaming era and
I haven't I also haven't really
Revisited full albums even from when I
was younger
so it's hard for me to say now
um I can tell you when I was in Middle
School early High School I latched on to
Pink Floyd The Wall and I latched onto
it hard
uh that was a big one I also discovered
Tom Waits I think it was actually his
first album Nighthawks at the diner I
used to listen to that one a lot too
these days I think the only thing I
listen to as full albums are
um our musicals soundtracks to musicals
you know movies or Broadway or what have
you but you know the fact that I listen
to those is full albums is more about
the fact that it's an incomplete
experience if you don't then like some
idea that they are my favorite album so
like these days I'm not sure I could say
um nostalgically like going back to you
know when I used to listen to albums
more often I would say uh Nighthawks at
the diner or the wall those were some
big ones
um
uh
you know what
um
the rent soundtrack The Broadway one and
I cannot remember the name of the uh the
album now but vertical Horizons album
uh the one that had everything you want
on it that was a good album
I've heard it said the Democrats are a
moderate conservative party with a
left-wing base do you think that's
accurate well yeah
yeah no that is accurate that's that's
flatly accurate
uh did I hear about Tina Turner I did
that was unfortunate
Finding Nemo turned 20. good for Nemo he
can almost drink
how long do you think it will take to
beat the conservatives or at least make
the situation better than it is right
now well the first thing is to
understand never never classify
the conservative movement as being
beaten
if you're going to say the conservatives
have been beaten you always need to
append the phrase for now
because losing sight of that phrase
and losing sight of the fact that they
have never gone away and have continued
to work for decades for all the stuff
that they were working towards back
since you know the 50s and earlier that
that was still what they were after
and forgetting that they were still
working towards it
I've gone off on liberal complacency
before
Democrat the Democratic party and
I'm not going to say most liberals uh or
most left-leaning people I would say
middle class well-off liberals which is
not which is a dwindling population by
number but still basically is the
um philosophical heart of the Democratic
Party
they just kicked backed and went ah well
we won
we won abortion is legal
you know it's a guaranteed right ah we
won gay people can marry ah we can relax
now no you can't
no you can't because they don't go away
now
that is a somewhat pessimistic thing
but it's
um
it's it's very important
to remember
that
assuming they can't claw back whatever
gains have been made is a very
it's it's an assumption you make at your
own Hazard well actually this is
something you make at the hazard of
every and all oppressed group or
potentially oppressed group
to their Hazard do you assume that gains
made cannot be rolled back
because they can be if you are not
guarding them and the the Democrats
didn't they just they flatly didn't
um but to deal with the second half of
your question how long will it take to
make the situation better than it is now
I don't know
it's going to vary a lot depending on
where you live so like
for someone like me who let's be honest
has a lot of privilege
I am white
I am not in crippling debt I like my
bills are tight don't get me wrong but I
am not in crippling amounts of debt
and I uh live in a s in a state that is
very safe for people like me
so for someone like me for the situation
to get better basically is turning on
National politics so like
getting the conservatives out of a house
majority and ensuring that they don't
retake the presidency
from my perspective that would make the
situation better and that can be done
within the next election cycle
but there are other places like Texas
Florida
Etc where things have gotten so bad it's
going to take that much longer
to remove from Power the people who are
doing the damage and to then undo what
they did so
how long it will take to make the
situation better depends on where you
are and the exact nature of the
situation you are in the worse the
situation is the longer it's going to
take to fix
is is the short version
um we're looking at years
and
if we are being
brutally honest about it
I am looking to my kids generation
and I'm trying to make the world better
for her
because I don't know how much better I'm
gonna see it be within my generation
I don't mean better than it is now I
mean better than it ever was
I feel like the best I could ever hope
for within my lifetime is to basically
get back to where we were in 2011.
which wasn't great
it wasn't amazing
but we've been sliding for a long time
and
the best that I feel like I can
reasonably hope for within my lifetime
is to get back
to where we were and then try and get to
a better place from there
my goal
is to get the world as safe as I can for
my kid
that's I'm trying
uh
Owen Hachi Hachi Hachi Owen thank you
very much for the Super Chat as a trans
youth I just wanted to say you've been a
huge inspiration to me I appreciate
everything you do I want to say thank
you oh
thank you Owen I
appreciate that greatly
fortunately digital age of Music means
the ADHD ears can just skip around yeah
we can I'm not sure how good that is for
me overall but yeah I can
saw the new Little Mermaid I hope you
enjoyed it if you did
uh
don't you think that the magic of some
music such as Prague Rock and
soundtracks is lost when you listen to
music on shuffle some of it yeah not all
albums are meant to be listened to as
albums though like some some bands some
artists they just make collections of
songs I mean but let's be honest it's
just maybe there's you know if they're
smart there's some Rhyme or Reason but
it's like it's not a concept album one
song does not immediately build on the
next in a lot of cases so like
yes of some music I would agree with
that Robin
Nighthawks is Tom's third album I gotcha
speaking of the wall people have been
trying to cancel Roger Waters recently
given his age I'm sure he's said some
[__] if not recently then at some
point I don't doubt
seems like it takes months to make a law
in decades to repeal one yeah pretty
much
and that goes in both directions and
unfortunately that was why the Democrats
got complacent because you know they
spent
several years
you know working towards Shoring up
abortion as a right and it took decades
to undo that
but it was undone
so
I think you see the middle as
unacceptable because it's too close to
the right you wouldn't accept anything
less than mostly left is that a fair
assessment
um
ah
sort of like philosophically no
um
practically speaking kind of
um because like
centrists in America in American
politics are conservatives
I mean heck the the left quote unquote
in America is conservative is light
conservatism by most measures but like
Centrist political centrists in America
they are the right they are they are a
uh less rigid slightly more
um I don't like you but maybe I'm not
going to actively try and strip your
rights away but I'm also not going to
stop them from doing it kind of version
of the right
um and no I don't have a lot of use for
centrists
but broadly speaking no what I said
before is what I stand by which is that
when a position is so extreme
it doesn't matter whether or not I
consider the middle to be somewhat
conservative
meeting in the middle is unacceptable
again to come back to
you know the basic things that we're
looking at when it comes to the
destruction of knowledge that we are
seeing being done actively by the book
Bannings and the book challenges
you can't meet in the middle
with that what are you going to do let
them just destroy half the queer books
in the country
no
are you are you going to let them
um you know
put half the trans people
uh in jail for going in the wrong
bathroom like in some positions
you should not consider there to be a
middle ground with
because if a position is so extreme and
so hazardous
then giving it any ground means allowing
damage to happen just to a lesser degree
and I do not find that acceptable with a
lot of the stuff that the right is
pushing at the moment
so under the current Logistics of where
American politics are yes you're kind of
right within the broader philosophical
approach that I'm talking about no
that's not accurate
I'm from Texas but a part of Texas where
most people my age are left leaning but
older people like my family aren't
I I
yeah best of luck is is all I can say
I'm very lucky to live where I do and
like the odd thing is
I live in possibly the most conservative
corner of Vermont
um and like there is a fair chunk of my
family here who are all conservative
so I'm kind of
I'm kind of uh in a way almost in the
opposite position of you uh Alyssa
birthdays tomorrow turning 26 well I
hope you have something fun planned Ms
Wicked Wolf
so excited about the nimona movie but
I'm also slightly nervous that'll make
too many changes
I think it would have to though I think
that's a story that adapts pretty
cleanly as long as they don't compress
uh things too much
uh
so paper Smith I I I appreciate where
your head's at uh when you as when you
asked if I'm a mom
um I'm not now
before I say what I'm about to say I
need to be super clear that I'm speaking
for myself as a gender fluid person a
family and gender fluid person who does
not identify as a trans woman and do not
take what I am about to say in regards
to myself as a metric by which you are
to interact with or make assumptions
about any other
um trans or gender-fluid people
but I'm not a mom I'm a dad
to me and my relationship to both my kid
and to the word dad I don't personally
for myself
consider it a gendered term for me
being a dad is just accurate
I'm my kid's father the nature of that
relationship didn't change with my
transition I'll always be her father
now that's not how all trans feminine
people or trans people in general choose
to view it or wish to be addressed but
for me I'm not a mom and dad even though
I don't use them as healing pronoun
anymore wrap your head around that one
ah
do you mean ideologically or legally
back to 2011 because I think young
people will never be as transphobic as
they were in 2011 regardless of the new
law uh yeah no I'm talking about laws
and rights ideologically
things have been heading in a
progressive Direction and they pretty
much always have been ideologically
but no I I meant the legal protections
element of it
sitting on the fence is allowing things
to continue regardless of whether it's
good or bad or neutral yeah pretty much
did you see Nostalgia critics video
about the wall I never uh I never did
see Doug Jones uh review of the wall
I did see folding ideas video on
uh Doug Walker's review of the wall so
yeah I'm familiar with it I never did
watch it
how would you rank the five members of
Pink Floyd uh I don't actually think I
could name any of them besides
um Roger Waters and Dave Gill uh Gilmore
Gilmore see I can't even remember like I
I'm I'm not a good I I'm not good at
knowing band member names for any band
that I've liked
apparently there's an anti-centrist
weeping angel big finish story their
time travel power is a metaphor for the
fact that progress can be undone
interesting
huh
that is interesting
uh I should check the Discord in just a
minute so hang on let me see if I can
catch up on things what was your
favorite Doctor Who episode review to
film I'm not sure any of them really
stood out because the format's exactly
the same I mean
doing the uh the final rant on hell bent
was cathartic
certainly but like I don't necessarily
enjoy getting that upset either so I
don't really know if I have an answer to
that
uh are we the left and they the right
just playing tug of war uh with a meter
Arrow debating what qualifies as the
right or the left or conservative or
liberal
it like I don't find a lot of use in
that debate
you know I hate to default to uh to a
very weird Supreme Court decision but
much like they said about pornography I
don't know if I can define a
conservative but I know when I see one
and like splitting hairs over
terminology is not a good use of
anybody's time
I went to see the new Little Mermaid
just to show my support for black Ariel
that's fair I hope you enjoyed it
regardless of your reason for seeing it
just spammy you can't defend it in with
the others yeah sure why not
uh
uh I was very flattered when you liked
the end porn I posted on Twitter Hey
look
I I ain't gonna shame
uh okay so uh I see your uh Super Chat
uh Supreme
Omega I am gonna hop over to the Discord
real quick reminder Council geek's
Discord is a patreon perk and I'm gonna
check out questions that I have been
asked over there as quickly as I can
let's see
if you could make any episode of Doctor
Who uh and turn it into a dedicated
movie which would you pick and why oh
ah
oh geez I don't know if I actually have
an answer for that
um
okay I feel like maybe human nature if
you extend the front end uh a little bit
to
um to really bring
uh some emphasis on making sure the
audience gets time to know the doctor
audience who might not be watching the
show before he turns into John Smith and
then have it play out pretty much as is
that's that's the first one that's
coming to my mind I could probably think
of a better answer at a later date but
that's what I've got right now do you
think that Donna uh
uh do you think what Donna did with her
lottery winnings needs to be addressed
in the specials no not really
like she doesn't strike me as the kind
of person who would move into a mansion
so like as long as
um you know they aren't like appear to
be living in poverty and there's no
acknowledgment in having won the lottery
I don't think you actually need to
address it either way like just have her
seem fine look like oh that's a nice
house that's a decent car okay just
assume she's fine I don't think there's
any need to dig into it or like go
through her shopping habits have you
ever lost interest in a TV show but when
but then saw a new season or maybe even
a single episode that was so good that
you regained interest it happened to me
recently with stranger things
um
not really I've had some Seasons like
start to lose me a bit and then other
ones bring me back
but if I've genuinely decided to walk
away from a show if I'm like I'm done
with this I can't think of any show that
I came that I was pulled back to after
making the conscious decision to stop
I don't think that's happened
um there have been shows like obviously
Doctor Who their Seasons I don't like
all that much or you know even
um you know shows like Dexter or even
something like
um American Horror Story of which of the
five season I watched I really only like
two but that was the thing after after
realizing the batting average I was like
I think I'll just stop it I've never
really felt that strong need to go back
what is the best and worst film ending
in my opinion oh
I don't know
like I like I I I honestly I honestly
don't I can tell you what film all I can
tell you is what film ending is leaping
to my mind as an exceptionally good one
is the ending to the gray uh spoilers
for a decade plus old Liam Neeson movie
that I don't know how well remembered it
is but
that movie's ending is damn near perfect
because
it it cuts out at exact the moment it at
the exact moment when it answers the
important question and it realizes that
the follow-up on that question doesn't
matter
so without going through everything in
regards to that movie and everything
that's going on the movie cuts out at
the start of a physical conflict
and it like there's kind of a mid credit
scene that kind of handset the outcome
but like I honestly I ignore it and I
don't count it
but it it hard cuts the credits
because what matters is that the lead
character made the decision to fight to
enter that fight and that choice is What
mattered and whether or not he wins does
not matter because that was not the
question that the film was banged the
film was begging the question
will you continue to fight no matter
what
will you keep fighting and once that is
firmly answered yes
it doesn't matter
whether he wins or loses lives or dies
because the question the film was
actually answering has been has been
answered I have a lot of respect for
stories in general that basically end at
the point at which they have answered
the core question of their own narrative
um and that's not uh like belittle a
well-done or you know boy
sound like I finished college with words
like that I didn't but you know uh you
know uh wrapping up the I don't want to
belittle that or act like you can't do
some really good stuff with that but I
kind of respect stories that
to stop
as long as you do it at the right Point
as far as worst film endings oh
I'm kind of drawing a blank I mean I I I
had a series I used to do called good
movie Bad ending some of the ones I had
on there were like
um cabin in the woods and
um
hard candy
oh you know what it was I'll tell you
what it was it was a movie that I was
going to do as part of that series but
never got around to
Birdman
Birdman holds the record for completely
losing me with the least amount of time
left before the credits rolled that
record used to be held by Cabin in the
Woods which was about five minutes
before the credits it completely lost me
and Birdman lost me with about five
seconds left before the credits rolled
and it completely lost me and made me
just throw my hands up and go well screw
that to the entire movie
and not it's not because the last five
seconds were the worst thing ever
necessarily but like that was the point
at which the movie just flew up its own
ass so bad I'm like oh screw this
uh anyways you mentioned before that I
get the Christie's and then there were
none as one of your favorite books what
other Agatha Christie novels do you like
oh see the thing is that's the only one
I've gone back to and re-read as an
adult because I read Agatha Christie
starting in middle school and I don't
remember which ones I read
at this point like I bet if I were to
try and reread them I go oh right this
one in some cases but
uh unfortunately I don't really have an
answer because and then there were none
is the only one I've gone back to and
reread as an adult and the others kind
of blur together
ah sorry favorite Ben and Jerry's ice
cream flavor
um probably triple caramel chunk it was
vermontie python but they discontinued
it
all right oh boy okay I got I'll try and
get through these and get back on the
main chat so back in 2010 Family Guy did
a really transphobic episode and they
were called out uh for it Seth
macfarland got defensive about it
refused to apologize or even admit it
was bad representation to my knowledge
that's his sins to this day but more
recently the Orville did a really good
trans allegory with the character of
toppa my question is should you give
someone praise for doing really good
queer representation in their work if
formally they've been involved in really
bad queer representation and refused to
apologize or even a minute well the the
first thing to acknowledge is that Seth
MacFarlane
is very much someone who has solidarity
with writers he has fully supported the
writer strikes because what's happening
right now is the second Rider strike
that has happened during the Run of
Family Guy and he has fully supported
the writer strikes both time he has a
lot of solidarity with other writers now
he did not personally write that episode
I'm not saying that to let him off the
hook because while the next year in 20
in 2011 he did stop being involved in
the creative side and basically just did
voices he was still might have been the
showrunner at the very least he was
still involved in the creative decisions
in 2010 because I'm assuming you're
referring to the Quagmire's Dad episode
um so he was still involved then so he
he had the ability to veto that story
whether or not it was his idea in the
first place I don't know if that's ever
been confirmed but I think I am willing
to give some wiggle room that his not
apologizing for it might actually be
tied to the fact that he did not
personally write it and he is unwilling
to throw other writers under the bus
um because that was not his script and
like I said he has a lot of solidarity
with writers and I think he's not
apologizing for it might at least in
part come from not wanting to throw
other people under the bus if he'd
written it himself I'm not gonna say he
would have apologized but I think it's
more likely he would have gone yeah no
that was bad if he was the one who'd
actually written that script because
nobody else would have taken the hit
then
um but uh well and the other thing I'll
say like I forget exactly what he said
to defend it what I'll say overall about
that episode is it's not the worst thing
in the world because
I do feel that
Ida as a character
is pretty well represented if I'm being
completely honest
and Quagmire as a trans woman's son
comes off as someone who was not
prepared for this but
he's trying
where it all goes off the rails is with
Brian and Brian's reaction when he
realizes that Ida is a trans woman this
is after he slept with her it is
incredibly overblown it is overwhelmed
for the purposes of Comedy I will point
out that by this point in the show the
show had been increasingly digging at
Brian as a hypocrite and kind of an
awful person
I mean that's part of why Quagmire gets
so pissed off that that's who his dad
hooked up with because the whole uh
episode of Quagmire tearing down Brian
and pointing out all the very legitimate
criticisms that exist of Brian as a
character had already happened by this
point so I do think while it does not
negate the problem of one of the
characters that the audience is meant to
empathize with having a vomitous
reaction at realizing they slept with a
trans woman that's still bad but I do
think it is a somewhat mitigating factor
that by that point that character was
not was no longer being upheld as always
being right he was actually frequently
being pointed out as being an idiot
um it's and again that doesn't fix the
problem but I think it shows that there
wasn't a ton of malice intended and I
kind of I'll point to
um this stream's gonna go over because
I'm just like this is an ADHD stream I'm
just going off and my brain's going off
on its own places
I have similar feelings to
um and granted I haven't rewatched this
in a long time either but to the movie
Chasing Amy and there's a lot of um
issues that people take with what they
feel is uh part of the message of the
movie that you know this lesbian starts
dating a man and this idea that all she
needed pardon my language was a good
deep [__] the thing is and this is
important it doesn't fix the problem
because that is unfortunately
subtextually still kind of in there to a
certain extent it doesn't fix the
problem but it is kind of important to
note that the first person to say that
the one who promotes that concept
is the person in the movie who has
demonstrated repeatedly to be the
biggest idiot who is wrong about
everything
so again I think in both cases that
shows
um at least
a minimal amount of ill intent even
though there was stuff mishandled now to
get to your actual question
ADHD stream
to get to your actual question
um should you be giving praise for good
queer representation of someone who has
gotten it wrong before even if they
haven't apologized for that own work for
that old work short version yes
with caution see if they can maintain
that because if someone is producing
good representation but has not properly
grappled with their own bad
representation in the past I am not
necessarily going to let them off the
hook for that old representation but I
am not going to say we should not value
and say this is a good thing with the
new representation they've done just
keep an eye out and make sure that they
don't backslide because that's where you
get into a uh sweary issue if you know
video games
um because he was the director of Deadly
Premonition which had some not great
Trend stuff in it and then he did a much
smaller game called JJ mcfield and the
island of the missing or no missing uh
JJ Maxfield in the island of Lost
memories something some something like
that which actually had really good
trans representation but that was
because he actually brought on trans
consultants for that and then he did
Deadly Premonition too a few years later
and the horrible transphobic [__] came
roaring back again so like that is like
and so it's cases like that that make me
go
be on guard but if they've gotten it
right do praise them for that if for no
other reason than to show them that yes
we will we will say thank you when you
actually do good work
you know that doesn't mean you have to
forgive the old work but I do think if
somebody has gotten it right you should
tell them they got it right
she's I'm really gonna end up going over
okay apologies this just is what it is
at this point
my throat's getting dry from how much
I'm talking so recently the YouTube
Right lost their mind because Netflix
put out a show where Cleopatra was
played by a black woman yeah I saw that
I agree she probably didn't look like a
black woman but I think she also didn't
look like Liz Taylor or any of the other
white women who played Greek Egyptian
women so I don't see the issue agreed
that said something I wonder if part of
the reason the Netflix decision to
commission the show is they knew these
kinds of people would complain about it
and inadvertently give it free publicity
possibly even if people who actually
made the show sincerely want more POC
representation I don't think it's crazy
to imagine the capitalists above them
were cynically courting controversy
controversy somewhat I suspect there's
probably similar motivation to why the
Velma animated series was greenlit
um
uh I have the same suspicion about uh
Mars oh the Mars candy company every
time they alter Eminem mascots to make
them slightly less gendered and the
right goes insane to clarify I still
think the outrage itself is crappy but I
do wonder if companies intentionally
Court it sometimes oh yeah
yeah of course they do
because like it
it is a free free publicity
and
um you know especially in the case of a
piece of entertainment uh a hate view
spends just the same as a legitimate uh
we love this view so if you're going by
metrics of who's of how many people are
watching this it doesn't matter and it's
why like you know people like oh
everyone was hate watching Velma yeah
everyone was hate watching Velma so it
was really successful
um
when you are talking about the executive
class and the people at the top yes of
course there is this level of cynicism
to it absolutely
that doesn't mean so like I'll say the
same thing that I say about
um corporate Pride stuff
it's not enough
it's not and I don't like that it is
cynically motivated but
I would rather have the people who are
making calculations on where the money
is Express a belief that even appearing
to side with us or any other minority is
in their best interest I take as a good
sign regardless of the cynicism that is
underlying a lot of it
one of my favorite books as a teen was a
doctor who Tayan novel where he travels
back to Britain in the Ice Age the
author later turned out to be a Turf
which ruined the Nostalgia a little but
never mind that for now yeah well the uh
so many of them have suppose uh the
actual show decided to do an episode
like that uh what race should the actors
who played the Ice Age britons be I am
not an archaeologist an archaeologist or
an anthropologist so I do not feel
equipped to tackle that if Ice Age
Europeans were dark-skinned but probably
didn't look like any modern pocs because
they were entirely assimilated by
lighter skinned uh
agriculturalists who migrated into the
continent ironically from the near East
about 8 000 years ago how do you go
about trying to accurately represent an
ethnic group that uh literally doesn't
exist anymore honestly uh didn't set
about trying to come up with three
representation and media related
questions that's just how it worked out
I mean you you go for the closest thing
you have
um or
you just admit up front you're not doing
accuracy
and you know there's a there's a
separate conversation to be had over
whether or not accuracy should be
striven for regardless of whether it is
important to the specific story you're
telling
um more often than not it's a good idea
but you know if you can at least be
honest in your intentions and if you are
trying for accuracy whatever is the
closest
would be my own gut instinct but again
not an anthropologist not a sociologist
so I'm not going to make any specific
recommendations on that okay we're
almost done almost some of the Discord
questions hey there could you
um maybe make rose okay so this is a
very Discord specific
question
um so actually I'm not gonna answer that
on stream I'm going to answer that in
the Discord at a later time
all righty then
I am obviously uh not gonna be able to
catch up with the chat my lot is
probably
uh Gone on
Supreme Omega has come in with a couple
of super chats in the early 2000
thoughts on the shock humor of that era
with the whole let's offend everybody
energy Peak South Park Slim Shady era of
Eminem Etc
um I didn't mind it at the time
but I also felt that way from a position
of privilege from the position of
someone who
like oh they're making fun of me too and
at the time I was identifying as a CIS
white hat dude
like who cares if I was offended or not
uh the world wasn't out to get me
um
I don't think
I don't look back on it and think badly
on it I don't think very much of South
Park now the fact that they have
maintained that like it's some badge of
honor like it's a great thing to slam
everybody when some people very
demonstrably have it way way worse and
maybe you should lay the hell off
so but as far as at the time
I I I was okay with that at the time it
was probably even somewhat supportive of
it at the time
um I don't look back on it exceptionally
well even more so if I feel like the
people who are doing that back then
never grew which Trey Parker and Matt
Stone didn't so you know
um Supreme Omega again on Steven
Universe there's been criticism that
almost every villain gets redeemed even
the more monstrous flows like white
diamond do you agree
um
I've heard the criticism
and
I have had
concerns about that towards other pieces
of media
I don't
I haven't re-watched the finale of the
original run of the show in a couple of
years now
but at the time I saw it
which was long after it had aired
it worked for me
and I'm not sure how well I could
articulate
why
um but I know that that when it came
specifically to yellow and blue diamond
they brought in this whole thing of
um Stephen very literally getting inside
their heads and that was a big part of
what was certainly uh had me okay with
them because
um they made it clear that he was
connecting with them in a way that like
simple words and talking to them would
never be able to do
I don't remember enough about the
specifics of white diamond now I
remember being okay with that at the
time and thinking it worked pretty well
I do think that's a fair criticism and
I'll point to something like
um
the owl house
and kippo uh and the age of Wonder
Beasts where you have
um where you have protagonists who are
very I want to make friends with
everybody kind of people
but who also understand and are put in
situations where it was made clear
some people you can't
some people you can't you can't talk
them down you can't talk down Bellows
you can't talk down
um I cannot remember the scientist's
name uh all of a sudden from
um
from kippo but Amelia you can't talk
down Amelia you can't for who she is as
a person you cannot and sort of
realizing that was part of those
characters growing up
and
I
I will say that anyone who's who looks
at pieces of work like those
um or even like amphibia for that matter
and
comes to the conclusion that Steven
Universe was at least in its initial run
somewhat naive
I'm not going to disagree with that I do
think that Steven Universe future does a
fair bit to
um redress that and kind of answer
directly a fair number of those
criticisms
um with characters like Jasper and what
happens there and also just dealing with
the lasting trauma of what Stephen was
put through regardless of whether or not
uh everyone else was redeemed this still
hurt him in the long run so
I I feel like there's some
acknowledgment even from the show's on
continuation that
like there was stuff that wasn't
properly handled
so uh the short answer is I don't
disagree with the criticism I just don't
know how well I share it if that makes
sense like I do I don't have to share a
criticism to be able to agree with its
validity I do feel that's a valid
criticism it's one of those things it's
a question of how much does that bother
you
uh 255 A.T sorry for making you go over
the hour
it is what it is uh I should wrap it up
soon though
hey very long time no see I recently saw
the new
I'm assuming that's something Ruby
related
uh would you like to know my verdict I
mean you can
say what your verdict is I've never
watched
any of Ruby so it's not gonna have a uh
a lot of meaning
um you can't talk down Simon from
Infinity train that's true lingua but
um to my memory that's also something
so the way that that was handled like
the point at which that became 100 clear
was also like the point at which
uh it wasn't necessarily
a major point that the protagonist of
that season had to come to terms with
because everything was happening so fast
by that ending I do think it was the
moment when they learned that but I
think there's a bit of a difference
between something like say people in the
age of the Wonder Beasts where
um kipo like has to sit with the with
the understanding legitimately come to
terms not just in the moment because
things are so bad but like
before even going to confront Amelia
having to come to terms with the fact
that she can't talk her down and that's
I I feel like that's a little bit
different from how Infinity train
handled it and that's not to knock
Infinity drain Infinity Train's great
season three was
harrowing
to be completely honest I was there were
parts of that like I've got my review up
in the break room parts of that were
really unsettling like in a good way
have I ever read any Victor Hugo novels
nope never have
best entry point to reading slash
watching Shakespeare
uh 10 Things I Hate About You
Honestly though start with a
um somewhat modernized adaptation so
that you understand the ways in which
his stories still connect to a modern
sensibility before trying to deal with
any of the actual
um stories themselves and I would say
start start with start with one of the
comedies
um
start with Much Ado About Nothing or
um or as you like it
um
or or you know something along those
lines
ah
so yeah it looks like people are uh
starting to call it a night I should do
the same if any of them turn 70 oh geez
we are all getting old are we
why do pulp movies like Sky pirates in
the World of Tomorrow flop because the
percentage of people who were nostalgic
for it was
not a high enough box office percentage
and they didn't do a very good job of
luring in people who were not nostalgic
for that specific kind of thing
they they the degree to which the
um marketing of Sky Captain in the World
of Tomorrow tried to appeal to audiences
not already familiar with the kind of
material was it basically began and
ended with the casting it's like oh well
we've cast Jude Law in a year where Jude
Law was in way too many movies and
people were kind of burning out on them
and we've cast Angelina Jolie that'll
bring in the youths it didn't
Ruby X Justice League and as a DC fan it
was kind of insulting with its handling
of the Justice League I suppose it
depends on who uh
who was writing it if the Ruby folks
were writing it that wouldn't be
surprising Ian McKellen's version of
Richard III is a hard recommend that is
a good one that's a good solid one
um that and that one's pretty accessible
for folks
ever had the experience of not
understanding why a family member has
such different politics to you uh when
you have such similar personalities to
them otherwise that's me and my
conservative Dad no I haven't because
personality wise I'm
I'm very very different from my
conservative relatives
like the far end of it is my um
is my uncle and we have almost nothing
in common
like just in terms of outlook on the
world
both are owned by Warner Brothers yeah
but they still would have had primarily
one side or the other writing doing the
writing if that makes sense
can't stop thinking about the characters
in The Great Mouse Detective are
basically like the tethered from us
okay
[Music]
you can deal in most Shakespeare plays
well enough if you stop pretending like
Shakespeare's early modern English it's
just as hard to understand as chauzer oh
in Chaucer I had to read the Canterbury
Tales in college
[Music]
um
uh no 55 I know 255 A.D I did not see a
shaving question I missed it
oh I am going to call it a night
Great Mouse Detective American Tail came
out the same year huh I tend to forget
about that because Great Mouse Detective
got re-released
um a few times because Disney was still
doing that so I tend to forget when it
first came out
anyway
yeah we're gonna wrap it up I've gone uh
over how long I would normally like to
thank you all for
um
uh for joining me and yeah this one was
this one ran long this one was rambly
that's kind of just been my day
[Laughter]
so uh in any case please remember
that you are beautiful
you are valid
and you are loved
you are the council I am just running
the meetings and until next time this
Council
is adjourned
my cavity